chemise de relations avec le parlement
il y as exactement un an je vous posais
cette question d'actualité tout simple
le gouvernement va-t-il entendre le
sénat et depuis
malheureusement cela n'a pas été le cas
lors du ppt élèves de 2018 vous le savez
le sénat avait proposé la suppression de
la hausse de la fiscalité de l'énergie
jusqu'en 2022 et le 26 décembre dernier
le 26 décembre dernier le sénat a adopté
l'amendement que j'avais proposée je
lance cette trajectoire de fiscalité
énergie ignorant les avertissements du
sénat vous vous êtes opposés à ces
amendements l'an dernier nous avions
signalé les difficultés rencontrées par
les retraités je pense aux plus modestes
à la suite de la hausse de la csg que
nous avions contesté que cette année
nous avons dans le plfss refuser la
désindexation des pensions de retraite
ce que vous avez refusé également l'an
dernier comme cette année dans le cadre
de l'examen du budget nous avons pris
des mesures de lutte contre la fraude à
la tva nous avons également pris des
mesures de la fraude de lutte contre la
fraude aux dividendes et le gouvernement
n'y a pas donné son accord j'arrête là
de citer la longue liste des amendements
tous voté largement parfois l'unanimité
mais auquel le garnement s'est toujours
opposée avant parfois il est vrai de
reconnaître son tort alors je le dis
pourtant la majorité sénatoriale a
toujours chez le ministre fait preuve de
responsabilité puisque tous les
amendements notamment les amendements de
pouvoir d'achat ont toujours été gagée
par des propositions des économies mais
depuis quelques jours les choses ont
changé depuis quelques jours les
événements nous ont ramenés à la réalité
la semaine dernière le gouvernement
indiquait en effet par la voix du
premier ministre qu'il reviendrait qu'il
prendrait l'amendement du grandement sur
la fiscalité l'énergie et le présent de
la république a annoncé qu'il
reviendrait sur la question de la csg
des retraités
le sentiment qui est partagée
aujourd'hui par beaucoup c'est sans
doute que si on avait un peu coûter le
sénat nous n'en serions pas là
notre seul tort finalement notre sol
notre seul tort finalement n'est-il pas
eue d'avoir eu raison trop tôt
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est extrêmement simple allez vous enfin
écouter le sénat
ce menu
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
rapporteur général
j'entends bien votre interpellation
monsieur karoutchi c'est de répondre sur
le fond à votre question
le président de la république a fait un
certain nombre d'annoncés lundi sur la
csg sur le versement à partir de 2019
des heures supplémentaires sans impôts
ni charges sur le revenu des salariés du
smic sur la possibilité pour les
entreprises je vais sur la possibilité
pour les entreprises de verser à leurs
salariés une prime exceptionnelle de fin
d'année de fin d'année sans impôts ni
taxes sur le renforcement la justice
fiscale ces mesures s'ajoutent vous
l'avez rappelé le rapporteur général à
l'annulation de la hausse des taxes sur
les carburants que le premier ministre a
annoncé la semaine dernière
mardi dernier le sénat a bien voulu
accepter la seconde délibération
demandée par le gouvernement sur le
projet de loi de finances de 2010 neuf
afin de permettre l'accélération de la
hausse de la prime d'activité jouer en
présentant remercié le président de la
haute assemblée le rapporteur général le
président et blaye et l'ensemble des
sénateurs et des sénatrices qui ont fait
oeuvre vous le rappelez de
responsabilité en l'occurrence reste les
autres mesures
plusieurs options sont allées étaient à
l'étude s'agissant des modalités de mise
en oeuvre
j'ai adressé ce matin même à monsieur le
président du sénat une lettre au nom du
premier ministre modifiant l'ordre du
jour de la semaine du 17 décembre afin
de tenir compte du report de la loi de
programmation et de réforme de la
justice afin de tirer les conséquences
de ces mesures annoncées par le chef de
l'état je serai amener d'ici lundi a
adressé au président larcher une
nouvelle lettre d'or du jour qui doit
permettre aux assemblées de se saisir
aux assemblées de se saisir très
rapidement dans le calendrier contraint
qui est le nôtre et avec l'exigence des
promesses qui ont été faites devant les
français de tenir compte des exigences
constitutionnelles et de répondre aux
exigences de bon travail de la
représentation nationale comme bien
l'indiquer le premier ministre un projet
de loi sera examiné en conseil des
ministres dès mercredi prochain
et sera soumis à l'approbation des deux
assemblées
avec pour être objectif qui se puisse
être adoptée avant la suspension des
travaux du mois de décembre c'est à dire
avant la fin de la semaine prochaine et
je suis sûr monsieur le rapporteur
général que nous serons à la fois tirer
exigences de ce que dit senna de ce qui
veut dire à l'assemblée nationale pour
tirer le meilleur parti pour les
français de la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes et je sais votre esprit de
responsabilité pour le faire merci